hallo mein name ist luca war der liebe
freunde ich habe ja euch er lucio gesagt
dass sie mir gern mal auf instagram eure
neujahrsvorsätze schicken könnt und da
dort so viele ankamen dachte ich mir
dass mehr ganz geil wenn ich darauf
glaube ich meinem youtube-video
reagieren würde deswegen starten wir
auch direkt mit dem ersten
neujahrsvorsatz länder lautet heiliger
frohes neues ja ich habe mir für 2022
vorgenommen meine sitznachbarin der
schule immer abschreiben zu lassen weil
er nie gelernt und ich will dass er
besteht
großer schau dort an den sitznachbarn er
war genauso blöd wie ich hey lukas ich
will dieses jahr immer um passende
socken aussortieren weil meine mutter
sich sonst aufregt wenn ich löchter habe
ps ich liebe euren podcast
das klingt nach brenner machen du siehst
das eh nicht aber ich habe mir für den
januar vorgenommen 31 tage lang nur
dinge zu essen auf die ich gar keinen
bock habe grüße stanley formieren ich
finde sie cool als dich spaß danke dass
ich glaube liebe grüße bekomme ok luca
meine beste freundin und ich haben uns
vorgenommen dieses jahr nicht mehr bei
whatsapp zu schreiben wenn wir
nebeneinander sitzen weil wir immer
lässt an hh
warum redet ihr nicht
könnt ihr neben dann
das
wahrscheinlich schulen
hängt ihr handy passt mal auf machbar
was eure zukunft sage ich und mache mich
hier im internet zum affen also das ist
nicht mein vorsatz aber mein bruder will
einen fluchtweg in sein zimmer bauen
damit er in seiner unordnung flüchten
kann wenn ein notfall ist er 12 jahre
ich will eigentlich gar nicht wissen wer
also meine zuschauer sind bei luca ich
hoffe dieses jahr kommt viel neue merger
weil ich jetzt immer sparen will und mir
deinen neuen word zu kaufen um mein gott
was süßes du was ich je gesehen habe
aber ja es kommt neuer möchte ich weiß
nur noch nicht wann oder wie aber die
url kennt ja glaube ich alle
wegen den neujahrsvorsätzen ich will
unbedingt ein neues kaninchen haben weil
ich habe erst 5 und 6 ist meine
[Musik]
lieblingsschuhe ich hatte nicht aber ich
liebe euch irgendwann hast uns irgendwie
ein bisschen größer weil luca ich will
dieses jahr besser werden in der schule
war ich schon zweimal sitzen geblieben
bin aber meine schwester ist autor
einmal sitzengeblieben kannst du bitte
diener in der nächsten podcast folgen
ist alles solche idioten nütze das
siehst ich habe mir vorgenommen dieses
jahr mehr alkohol zu trinken das klingt
komisch aber ich vertrage so wenig und
habe immer einen absturz wenn ich auf
partys trinken gehe meine freunde lacht
nämlich immer dafür aus dieses jahr
lerne ich das an der stelle liebe grüße
am steller ich glaube das kommt von dir
haben ihr habt mir die sachen übrigens
ausgesucht also die neue assistentin und
sandra und mir also ich hab ja alle noch
nicht vorgesehen
gerne alle zuhause construction ferrari
die machten super joker lucas ich hab
mir gar nichts vorgenommen weil ich mich
eh nicht daran halten
können hamm ii zu klatschen weil
irgendwie sind die teile auch alles
scheiße ich vergesse so oft abzuspülen
nach dem toilettengang meine freunde
wird immer richtig sauer deswegen nehme
ich sie für mich fühlt nehme ich mir für
sie vor daran zu denken hoffen wir ich
hoffe dass ich muss immer frauen ein
bisschen deutsch zu denn im nächsten
jahr ich will mich dieses jahr
selbstständig machen und online meine
getragenen schuhe und socken verkaufen
weil es genug leute mit fuß fetisch gibt
falls sie das nimmst will ich bitte
anonym
bleiben ja ich diese nehmen glaube ich
da die profilbilder so mit reingenommen
es auch mal stark immer wenn ich
irgendwie auf instagram eine story
hochladen wie ich meine wohnung laufen
dabei aus versehen weil meine socken
film oder so ich kriege immer so
nachrichten von seiten mit 700.000
followen so hey keine post is amazing
feed
lukas ich nehme mir vor mich nicht immer
schnell aufzuregen aber bei den leuten
in meiner umgebung fällt mir das immer
so schwer danke du sprichst mir aus der
seele ich will single bleiben arm und
fett seien bis jetzt ist auch immer das
gegenteil passiert vielleicht klappt es
gibt so bitte nicht so ernst nehmen okay
das aber auch eine gute idee weil man
nimmt sich so oft irgendwelche dinge vor
und genau das gegenteil ist der fall
gerade wenn es um so lernen geht für
klausuren oder so sagt man immer so ich
habe die klausuren drei wochen das heißt
wenn ich jetzt jeden tag lernt dann
komme nicht richtig gut damit durch wann
fängt man an drei tage vorher
auch eine nacht folgt so wie ich es auch
richtig dass mit dem papier und so
geschafft hat luca ich will mein studium
endlich bestehen weil ich davor schon
zweimal was abgebrochen habe aber wenn
du ein studium bestanden hat dann
schaffe ich das auch oder
das passt ganz gut da und mich so
richtig wusste wie ich mein abi
geschafft aber ihr studium auch keine
ahnung ich das hingekriegt hat ein luca
ich will zeichnen lernen damit ich immer
bilder von mir verschenken kann statt
jedes mal was zu kaufen meine mutter
freut sich immer über sowas ist aber süß
aber
genau genommen ist im vorgenommen ist
eine intention er mit dem zeichnen
anzufangen nur weil du dein geld sparen
das kann ja auch nicht der richtige
ansatz bei uns neues jahr wünsche ich
dir ich will einen flirtkurs belegen
weil ich es nicht schaffe jungs
anzusprechen ich brauche man flirtkurs
ich lerne gerade mich zu schminken weil
ich finde es sieht viel besser aus bei
mir meine eltern erlauben ist auch weil
ich jetzt 15 wäre bord 15
obwohl das ist gar nicht so früh in der
mädels die linken sich noch ich habe
auch letztens in meiner instagram sorry
hab ich das video hier geteilt unnormal
krass das ist einfach ein mädel die ihre
bilder immer mit dieser fälle bearbeitet
derzeit wie sie unbearbeitet aussehen
ich glaube mittlerweile niemand mehr was
im internet ich esse so ungesund und
habe oft verstopfung deswegen muss ich
dieses jahr öfter scheißen gehen hh
perfekte gar danke für deine
neujahrsvorsatz ich will aufhören
fingernägel und fußnägel zu knabbern
ich bin ganz ehrlich habe noch nie
verstanden dass machen konnten
es ist doch ekelhaft dass er genau wie
puppen fressen hey lukas ich will nie
wieder von alkohol kotzen silvester war
zu wild aber das kennst du bestimmt ich
habe auf dem sofa gelegen und film
geguckt
ich habe seit zwei monaten einfach kein
alkohol mehr
trinke nur kenner podcast neujahrsfeier
habe ich besoffen wie sonst was ich habe
mir vorgenommen nichts mehr mit zu viel
älteren frauen zu haben meine freundin
jetzt soll in meinem alter sein
luca das klingt vielleicht ein bisschen
komisch aber ich will mich trauen das
erste mal von meinem freund zu furzen
das klingt überhaupt nicht komisch
also das aber also ich kann es verstehen
dass man sich das erstmal nicht traut
aber wenn man irgendwie dann ein
bisschen kloster ist von der beziehung
und sodann ist etwas völlig normales
ich habe einen guten vorsatz sehen sich
alle zu herzen nehmen sollten nicht mehr
das gleiche handlung für mein gesicht
und meine eier zu nehmen das verstehe
ich halt nie
wenn man aus einer dusche kommt ist man
an seinen eiern genauso frisch und
sauber wie hat in seinem gesicht
das denke ich mir auch mal wenn man
irgendwo auf toilette geht und man
pinkelt und hält halt sein in der hand
und lässt sich danach die hände also ich
glaube das sauberste was du in diesem
raum angefasst hast ist halt ein dings
wisse wie ich mein ich
wechsele jetzt in der woche öfter meine
socken her
ich hoffe mal das kam von sandra die
stehen nämlich immer ziemlich
wissen ich dachte wird auch noch nie von
seiner amazing feed seite angeschrieben
weil das wäre cool haft aber gut kommen
wir nur noch zum letzten jahres vorsatz
meiner liebe freude den haben hier
vorbereitet hat um zwar kein luca am ein
vorsatz für 2022 ist mehr auf die umwelt
zu achten und mehr recycling zu
betreiben wenn du weißt was ich meinen
zusammen ich bin nur
dass man mich
ja freuen der stellte sich dann die
heutige episode luca reagiert auf
neujahrsvorsätze der lupo auch beenden
wenn es euch gefallen hat dann das kann
einen daumen hoch unter dem video hier
abonnieren kann ein und klickt auf die
blogger werde weitere videos nicht
verpassen wollen wenn ihr auch in
solchen videos mal vorbei dabei sein
wollt oder denn hier einfach nur coole
story sehen wollt und alle zwei monate
ein neues foto dann folgt bin gern auf
instagram laserdrucker genauso heftig da
bin ich auch aktiv und wir sehen uns auf
irgendwann dann demnächst sehen wir uns
wieder ciao